hi everybody comedian and actress
cristela Alonzo was the first Latina to
create produce and star in her own
Network sitcom cristela she's here with
us now and now she has a new book music
to my years a mixtape memoir of growing
up and standing up so she joins us now
this is a book that's published by atria
which is an imprint of Simon & Schuster
which is a division of CBS she is here
in the Toyota green room we're so happy
to have her here with thank you so much
oh yeah it's so good to be here at CBS I
just I feel at home right here oh good
we're also here celebrating Hispanic
heritage yes so much of your book is
about your culture your background
growing up first-generation American on
a border town named San Juan which led
to some confusion yeah you when you had
growing up because I thought you were
Puerto Rican I thought I was well you
know people asked me why did you think
you were too Rican and I'm like well
because when you're a kid you don't say
the state that you're from like I didn't
like when people asked me I'm not saying
oh I'm from San Juan Texas I don't know
people we don't talk in States right so
then I would hear San Juan you know on
TV in movies and they were like my color
yeah so I was like oh my god I Puerto
Rican and then like one day my mom was
like no like you're like you you're
Texan and it's funny because even in
Texas we love being from Texas right but
even the flags were kind of similar to
me that's yeah yeah you know I'm like
you got to go with me it's kind of
similar right next essential identity
crisis at a young age yes
so since it's Hispanic Heritage Month
you know what is it what do you want to
share with people about being Hispanic
about what you love about you know like
in America in Texan it's a very simple
thing actually I want to remind people
that I'm just like everybody else and I
think that's such a hard reminder to do
at certain times because everybody wants
when they when they ask me a question a
lot of times they want to hear the
Latino version of an answer it's like
well how about I just give you an answer
right
and if you were to write it out and show
it to people you wouldn't guess that a
latina said it you know so how about
treating my life like everybody else's
life we that's why actually I format at
the book with music right because for me
music is such an equalizer
everyone has songs that we love right
for different reasons it's weird how if
we break up with someone we listen to
love songs even though we don't have
that love Adele Someone Like You and for
some reason it makes you feel good to
feel bad but you also have those songs
that remind you of great things that
have happened in your life and for me I
wanted to use music because I love music
I listen to hours of it every day but
there's songs in there that you wouldn't
assume that I like yeah because
everybody makes assumptions of what you
might write based on what you look like
right there's a lot of classic rock in
here so what I love about you what you
do is you organize it chapter based on a
song yeah like represents that moment in
your life and this is really a love
letter to the 80s and 90s
yes growing up first generation American
no matter where your family's yes I mean
there was a lot that identified with and
I'm first-generation American my parents
are from the Dominican Republic and you
know when you talk about sadena yes like
being a goddess and dreaming of you was
the yes the song for that chapter yeah
yeah well you know and it's so funny
because that chapter Selena spoke to me
I feel like selena quintanilla not Gomez
I always have to specify now because I'm
like oh there's another Selena but like
with named after the exact I get so like
mind blown but like selena quintanilla
is one of those iconic images where
people that love her love her and it's
hard to explain to other people that
aren't familiar with her why you love
her and for me Selena to me it was with
someone that was so ordinary so normal
that she was so extraordinary it was so
she was so like everyone we knew she she
actually served as a chance like a hope
for me that I could do something great
because she had done something great
and she was herself yeah you know so
it's it's hard to explain it and that's
why I wanted to take the chapter to
write it well I think you know you talk
about representation you talk about
watching a movie I think white knight
yes white knight in Spain Gregory Hines
yes tap-dancing yes and you created tap
shoes using what like bottle caps like I
stuck bottle caps at the bottom of my
little like Dora the Explorer white
velcro sneakers and you talked about
seeing him yes he wasn't Mexican no but
that that even was represent
representation for you well you know it
for me I grew up in a border town right
next to Mexico so in my neighborhood we
didn't have diversity we were all
Mexican American Mexican you know so we
didn't really have a lot of interaction
with white people black people age like
it was just us so you grew up in a
bubble you know and for me I always say
that when you're craving to have your
story told you really seek out the
connections wherever you find it and for
me when I saw Gregory Hines I saw
someone that wasn't white and you know I
was a little kid when I saw it so I
couldn't even understand race culture
like for me it was just like this guy
looks like me or like my relatives and
he's doing something extraordinary that
I've never seen before and that's a lot
of that's a lot of the book it's talking
about how for me I am very grateful for
the black community like like pop music
TV film because for me that was the
closest to representation that I had for
a long time you know and for me it was
something that really helped me
understand that that other people had
similar struggles that the communities
had different like the same ideals that
it wasn't you know it's funny how like
in politics Latinos get asked about
immigration right but we also care about
education you know we also care about
the economy you know it's so it's it was
this nice connection where you realize
that even if we look different and come
from different parts a lot of us have a
lot of things in common you know and
Gregory Hines was that thing for me or
like years later looking
back I don't know like I don't know why
it was appealing but it you know but at
the same time I'm thinking it's because
I was really craving someone that kind
of looked like me to do something that I
didn't know was possible and you say
seeing him tap-dance in this movie me do
you think that you could do the same
thing and you spend hours upon TV
learning those moves and had that person
been white you maybe he wouldn't have
done that yeah well you know it's like
Baryshnikov seen the movie right
Baryshnikov amazing ballet for a dancer
I mean one of the best and you know for
me I was familiar with the idea of
ballet at that point because girls at
school had been taking ballet classes
tap was different ballet was about this
beautiful art form that's very graceful
and for me tap I was such an energetic
kid that the tap the movements that was
more of like that was more of the beat
like that was more of like what
connected with my personality you know
what did your mom say to you when you
asked her to take dance class I asked my
dad straight if I could take dance
classes I didn't even know they were
thing and my mom super sarcastic was
like oh no post it give it take the
dance classes and then go tell your
brothers that they're not gonna eat
because you have to dance look you know
that was it and I'm like oh I can't I
can't dance right up which is why I made
the tap shoes that's when I learned that
a lot of times we give we think that the
economic status that where we're from
gives us limitations and sometimes it
does right but also if you really love
something you can find a way to be part
of it
and to learn about it despite not having
money because the knowledge thankfully
with the internet and everything that we
have is more available and technically
kind of free
I saw your stand-up special and you're
like okay guys for those of you who
don't know what an encyclopedia it's the
Internet in books it's so weird it's so
weird I'm at that age now where I talk
about the technology I grew up with and
then people were like what is that like
the VCR you get to the point where you
even say MySpace and people are like
what what is that is that like tik-tok
but quicker like and you're just like oh
my god like myspace was a thing not too
long ago but now it's like obsolete you
know so how do you grapple with the fact
that you grew up you say a lot in the
book a latchkey kid home alone for hours
on end and and TV was your first friend
right keeping you company you formed
relationships with the with the four
Golden Girls you were the fit yeah your
mind yeah so like now you had your own
TV show Christina you're providing that
representation you're now in you were in
people's living rooms you do this but
they're stand-up and now your book how
does that feel for you to be providing
that comfort that companionship for you
know like you I think that when we talk
there's a lot of talk especially
especially right now with Hispanic
Heritage Month we talk about
representation being important in TV and
film and on screen but I also say that
it's important to do it behind the
screen too because if we don't have
decision makers that that understand the
journey it's hard to actually have a
journey to you know to tell for me
everything I do and it's not for
everybody but my journey has always been
to tell my story and give the
programming that little me would have
loved to have seen so for me you know my
show was cancelled four years ago and
people always ask me why haven't you
come back to TV why haven't you come
back to TV and he always told them I
don't have a story to tell yet I don't
want to do anything for money I want to
do it because pop culture was my best
friend growing up and I I treat it with
so much love and so much respect that I
only like to tell stories that that
speak to me because I think that that's
the only way of making sure that it
connects with the audiences so for me
you know it's like this book it's
incredible to me that I wrote it because
I come from a neighborhood where people
like me are always told you can't you
know and when you're told that you can't
there's a lot of people that will just
accept it as an answer but then you
gotta take the extra step and ask why
and if they don't give you a good answer
to why you can't do it then you realize
that that's not a legitimate answer
that's just something that they have
been told and they're repeating that for
something else so for me I love what I
do
and this book was very special to me to
me it's such a love letter for
everything that made me understand where
I was in this country my Spanish is my
first language I was born in the United
States but also I think it gives people
a chance to understand that if you come
from nothing but you want something you
can get it and even when you come from
nothing you're absolutely something so I
hope that people read this book and
connect with it because it's it's just a
big thank you to everything that
influenced me and you know the catch
phrase from the Golden Girls thank you
for being a friend
so that catch phrase got you in trouble
got you in the principal's office so
many stories in this mess so much to
read so inspiring your background
growing up with your family and the
Family Values your mother there's so
much here you guys can all get this
today this is when your book drops today
wherever you buy your books online
in-store pick fill alone so thank you so
much for being with thank you so much
for having me thank you
bye guys